they're just going to pull out the covet
card and that's what they're going to do
that's why it hasn't gone away that's
why a certain amount of people are still
so obsessed with it this is
from the herald sun in australia look at
this this is today i just saw this today
giving your co-workers and family
members the silent treatment and texting
not talking could be the key to getting
the covid pandemic under control here's
why and then of course they link to this
thing speaking for just four words
speaking just four words an hour
increases the spread of coven 19 10
times more than breathing normally
well i have to tell you guys uh there's
four of us in a relatively small studio
here and i've been talking this entire
time if you get out of here alive it'll
be a freaking miracle phoenix is
literally coughing right now
but trust me
if you if you think i'm making this all
up don't listen to me right don't listen
to me what am i who am i again i'm a guy
with a jacket with some hairspray and a
sharpie don't listen to me about any of
this stuff listen to joe
biden
mr president are you
confident you have i know you looking
for more money from congress for
this vaccine campaign and for for covet
funding going into the fall
how much of the supply of vaccines for
these small children
uh is there and and how
many of the nation's kids will you be
able to get vaccinated before you need
more money from congress well we'll get
through at least this year we do need
more money but we don't just need more
money for vaccines for children
eventually we need more money to plan
for the second pandemic there's going to
be another pandemic we have to think
ahead
and that's not something the last outfit
did very well that's something we've
been doing for fairly well that's why we
need the money
oh
did you guys hear that uh second
pandemic yeah it's coming i don't know
how he knows that no i get it
kovit will continue to morph and we'll
get these variants and all of this stuff
and we had omicron after
delta and omega and whatever and you
know they'll change and usually they
become less lethal even though the
original version of kovid was far less
lethal than they were scaring us with
way back when but he knows that it's
coming and what does he need well he
needs more yo money you gotta get him
some money so not only can he vaccinate
the children even though there's no
evidence that the children should be
vaccinated but he needs money to do
other things because in the fall it's
coming back and of course he then said
that he's done better than the previous
administration even though far more
people have died of covid under uh
joseph r biden the elderly man
pretending to be president than donald
trump can i get the numbers on that how
many died under trump i think it was
around 200 000 if i'm not mistaken and
how many have died under uh joe biden
because let's let's get that let's
figure that out and uh just in case in
case you missed it here's just a small
sig a small snippet of what i just
showed you to really drive home the
point it's coming back baby
we need more money to plan for the
second pandemic there's going to be
another pandemic we have to think ahead
and that's not something the last outfit
did very well that's something we've
been doing fairly well that's why we
need the money
they're bringing it back they are
bringing it back uh 400 000 people uh
died under trump uh related to covet so
i was off a little bit on that one i'm
doing some of this off the top of my
head and uh 600 000 died under biden and
they were they both roughly had you know
a year and a half of covet under each of
their administration so you know uh at
200 000 which is why i said that number
that's when joe biden sent out that
tweet saying that if 200 000 people died
he shouldn't be trump shouldn't be
president anymore well more people have
died yadda yadda you get it but what's
this all about it's about fear right
this is this is the distraction they
can't they can't distract you with good
things they can't be like oh look at all
the great things that are happening
right now guys everything's really
fantastic the economy is doing well
people have jobs everybody's happy hey
let's get out let's party they can't do
that they want virus number two and why
do they want virus number two so that
you will not look at your bank account
so you will not look at your 401k
and so that they can basically blame
anything other than themselves for this
oncoming recession